come back to you know your generations
ability to kind of merge art and and
commerce which I think is important
because that was also I think a bit with
with Ken representing the Warhol's on
the Rauschenberg's and the pop artists
who kind of came after who really were
able to synthesize art and commerce
brilliantly but speaking of Felicity and
some of the amazing I mean just going
through your your filmography and and
the work you've done you've worked with
some amazing ensemble casts and some
brilliant directors but you actually
seem very gifted at two handers as well
or not as well but maybe you know kind
of rarely so that you know I'm thinking
theory of everything which folks will
see soon if they haven't already My Week
With Marilyn Savage Grace and and read
and in theater this ability to care a
kind of carry either a picture or a play
on an intimate scale a very intimate
scale between two people I don't talk a
little bit about that if you have a
preference if you prefer the the grand
scale of lame is or you know or if they
both bring different things to you and
are fulfilling the only thing that I've
just sort of realized having done worked
for a few years now is just what what
scenario makes you work best and and for
me it's being given the environment to
be brave enough to screw up basically
and because I think often the most
interesting work happens when when I've
got an absurd idea it's probably absurd
can I try it and those directors that go
for sure do you know do it and it
normally fails and then but those
directors are going to try again rather
than going it's costing money all of
this other stuff is that that's when I
tend to do most interesting work now
part of that is trusting the people
around you and so maybe what you're
referring to as far as the the more
intimate element of working in two
handers is that of course when you're
working with someone that intensely you
you develop that relationship and you do
trust each other and you have the
ability to to be braver and to and again
to sort of make mistakes
but what I'm forever and having started
in theater and really being really
illiterate as far as film is concerned
when I when I look at amazing screen
performances and think that that actor
may have met the person playing his
mother 30 seconds before the camera
started rolling everyone including
myself I used to go
yeah but they haven't have as many takes
as they want they really can't they
really really can't like whatever that
first instinct is is often the thing
that's caught and so I'm in great
admiration for people that can really
make you believe when there is no
generally in film now particularly there
is no rehearsal time but one of the
great gifts of the theory of everything
at the Hawking film is that is that
James gave his time he gave us so he
gave me four months to prepare well that
that would seem especially critical in
this sense because it was not only the
you know the the verbal but also the
physical very much in that which may be
the theatrical performance is lent to I
mean read was also in a way a very
physical performance as well so what
happens when it doesn't work you've been
in a few projects I know we're here to
talk about how great is don't worry
we're not gonna linger on this stuff but
you've been in a few that haven't worked
oh my god what happened like so talk no
not hundreds it's a few coin I won't I
won't name them because I don't do that
but can you can you tell as it's
happened like as you're making it and if
so do you panic like cut or is it never
that has it not been the case so far
that you can tell as it's happening oh
god this is a turd like god I move on
that's a great question and it's one
that it's like a constant like that's
that's the unknown that's why people say
don't invest in the film industry there
is no guarantee and I've done films with
literally extraordinary casts and you
know really formidable scripts that I'm
like oh we're safe here this is gonna be
and I'll be a bit part but like I know
I'm gonna be part of something wonderful
in it and it really won't work and on
the other hand I've done the opposite I
really it's very easy for me to to
choose theater and um and it helps that
I'm I suppose I've been lucky with the
theater so I have a bit more choice
there and there I just go okay this is
like a proper equation right imagine
that
rehearsals a nightmare we all get on
horrific Lee and then we open we get
horrific Lee reviewed no one comes and
sees it is there enough in in a text is
there enough in a character that three
months on when you're performing to you
know you know quarter of the house is
there enough there to keep you going and
that's that's literally the sort of the
rulebook that I try and use with film
you can't do that I mean it's that there
is the I did I describe it as alchemy
there's something else that happens and
the sort of control freak part of you
can't can't um you can't control
everything and and you've never been
discouraged obviously not to the point
where you stop working because you've
been thriving but I you know that's the
hardest part for me to imagine not being
artist myself for being a miserably
failed artist I can admit is worrying
that you put yourself out there and you
do have to trust your collaborators and
then when it doesn't work that that
somehow you're able to process that and
move on well the thing that I've learnt
I think subsequently is that
everything's there for a reason and for
example there's a film called the Yellow
Handkerchief which was with William Hurt
and Kristen Stewart was the scene in the
film there and I was playing an adopted
Native American from northern Oklahoma
and I I remember actually gene parsegian
my manager who's here
evening I member I was in town and he's
like there's this it's a wonderful
script and I read it I was like it is
beautiful is like you should go for an
audition I was like I'm never gonna cast
as an adopted Native American from
northern Oklahoma and he went he went go
to the audition that he and I went to
the audition and because I was so
convinced I didn't have a hope I just
sort of threw I described it's like
throwing mud at a wall I was like there
you go walked out and then and then I
got offered the part and I think I just
had to go and speak to the director to
sort of tell him that that what I'd done
in that audition was complete like you
know I couldn't do an actual part oh
it's like a sort of moment of absurdity
anyway we went through the making of
that film it's a little film it didn't
have a huge audience when I was speaking
to James Marsh again um for the theory
of everything the director with a theory
of everything he had only seen English
period dramas and those sort of ones
that I'd done and and he asked me on the
phone he said have you done anything
that's physically
outside of you I said why did this in a
film called Yellow Handkerchief and and
that film which really didn't make much
money didn't have a sort of broad I
don't know it wasn't broadly released
ended up being the reason that I got
cast in in the theory of everything
because he saw that the the mud on the
wall element or like the jumping off a
cliff element he was like oh this guy
can he's happy to jump off a cliff
anyway he died and and so that you know
there was a sense that in some ways
these things are maybe I'm not a
fatalist
that was
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]